il aura fallu attendre près de deux ans
pour revoir un sommet entre l'union
européenne et la chine des retrouvailles
par visioconférence qui arrive en pleine
guerre en ukraine elle sera bien sûr au
centre des discussions l'objectif pour
bruxelles mettre la pression pour
convaincre les chinois de ne pas aider
moscou la rencontre se concentrera sur
le rôle que nous incitons la chine a
joué pour exercer toute l'influencé et
la pression nécessaire sur la russie ce
n'était pas l'objet initial du sommet ça
le devient nécessairement
pékin n'a jamais condamné l'invasion
russe en ukraine parlant même de
préoccupation raisonnable de la russie
cette semaine le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov était
en visite en chine les deux pays n'ont
pas hésité à mettre en avant leurs liens
étroits la coopération entre la chine et
la russie n'a pas de limites il n'y a
pas de limite pour nos deux pays pour
faire des efforts pour obtenir la paix
préserver la sécurité et s'opposer à
l'hégémonie
la crise actuelle vient crise perd un
peu plus les relations entre pékin et
bruxelles la chine est désormais
considéré comme un rival systémique par
l'union européenne notamment sur le plan
commercial fin 2020 les deux parties
avaient signé un important accord
d'investissement mais il a été gelé l'an
dernier par bruxelles en réponse aux
atteintes aux droits de l'homme dans la
région du xinjiang